you Epson piece of [ __ ] my blood is
boiling Avenue what my heart rate oh god
my heart rate is booming but before this
video gets started fully functioning
let's have a word from sponsor that's
right an ad in a video with ads in it
that's not annoying right giveaway time
giveaway time you could win chair this
chair not this chair as you guys know I
stream uhm deal I'm epically no and to
celebrate deal I'm joining the
BitTorrent family we're giving away free
defy chair it's an L ad 100 ml edition
chair thank you very much all you need
to do is to click link in description to
join Wow but Felix who BitTorrent
BitTorrent is the biggest decentralized
peer-to-peer file-sharing Network in the
world
powered by Tron blockchain which means
it has over 100 million users damn
that's almost as many as I had this
basically means more people can
seemingly asleep watch I said the big
deal I'm and support the creators over
there so if you want to sign up for D
life and that's a good time baby one of
the reasons I joined the alive is
because their mission is to not take any
of the streamers earnings and that's how
they support streamers in a huge way
ever since I joined them they develop a
ton of cool new features and it's been
really nice to watch it grow and deal
I've actually rewards you guys for
engaging with craters which others sites
don't do that and get this they also
have sticker feature sticker feature
which makes it even more interactive to
engage with streamer but yeah that's
pretty much it
catch me a deal I've check out the
giveaway and let's get on with the video
reddit review I like how everyone just
stop complaining about these finally
you've accepted it yeah this is just
part of the channel now today we're
reviewing [ __ ] design which it says
bad design but meant to freak you over
which is the worst kind
that's like the most passive-aggressive
way to fly went over this actually makes
me want to be a designer just to mess
with people there's so much bad design
people don't understand how important
design is okay youtuber gets every
single video on his channel copyright
claim despite having the rights to all
the music in his videos mumbo jumbo
mambo jump I loved his outro it was so
good
good this is so sad well it was based on
one small sample that was part of his
outro right that was the issue it's so
moronic that it blows my mind problem
here is in YouTube the problem is the
music industry what you use two seconds
of our clip that's mine mine the whole
YouTube video that has nothing to do
with it it blows my mind God and when I
think about I guess so angry
stop it Felix stop it the stranger thing
season 1 blu-ray has an unskipable ad
for season 2 that contains season 1
spoilers what the blu-ray why is that so
funny thank you for buying season 1
now buy season 2 government you owe as
money it's called taxes how much do I
owe
government you have to figure that out
me I just pay what I want government or
no we know exactly how much you owe but
you have to guess that number to me what
if I get to rock you got a present what
blows my mind
here in UK's I have to pay be 80 and via
T is based on I don't even know it like
when you sell step right or buy stuff or
higher stuff I generally it's just me or
I have the simplest business of all time
it's just me recording videos I don't
have that many driver new streams it's
not that complicated but still
government makes an estimate of v80
saying okay based on your income you
probably have to pay this amount in v80
which is pretty large amount of money
it's like 20 percent or something but
surprise surprise
I never have any v80 costs or taxes
because that's not how my business is
run but I still have to pay in advance
this estimate that the government wants
me to pay and if I forget to pay it or
if I don't pay it in time they charge
you 20 percent of that amount
it's a [ __ ] scam like it's not taxes
it's just a way to trick people into
paying money it's like a parking tickets
and [ __ ] I don't understand Arviat he is
it's a goods and service tax yeah
government we think you're gonna have to
pay this hundreds and thousands and v80
even though historically your business
never needs to pay it but we still want
you to pay it and then we'll
you back the money but if you don't pay
us in time we'll charge you 20 percent
of that amount because shame on you
because apparently you don't tax enough
yeah I get it
rich person complains about taxes it's a
cliche but it it is so dumb that it
makes me angry petition to change the
logo of this sub I gotta say despite
removing the headphone jack and how
stupid and annoying that was at first
now it's kind of like well I guess I
didn't really need it did I know that
you have wireless headphones as a
standard right it's like oh actually
it's quite nice to not have cables
everywhere even though I loose these all
the time it's freakin annoying Wow
McDonald's now blocks out the entire
menu to show a emitter so great design
makes it really easy so great here's a
flow chart I don't like it
by design No Mylene fury ating yes on
purpose no Trevor design yes that's
unremovable ads on my 2500 Samsung Smart
TV uh yeah we got it can't live without
those but if you pay one dollar a month
we can remove ads from your TV
shut up Angry Birds shut up the y-axis
has zero on the top so the graph looks
like the gun death went down stead of up
yeah why is it upside down this is how
the graph looks like oh my god who made
this that's so smart oh is this the same
size no [ __ ] way oh this makes my
blood boil no say it ain't so
no oh my God my life lie my life like
well was that filled to the rim though
was the original one filled it was out
no it isn't really filled to the rim is
it to be fair we always have these left
ones in UK Thank You UK you haven't had
those over yet um beer at least
collegeboard charging $12 per school to
send your test score electronically then
an extra 31 if you want to receive them
within one to two business days they're
electronic not actual shipping they make
you
pay to set a test you already paid over
fifty pounds to make that's crazy it's
like these old costs that they've
established like oh we have to send it
to you so that's gonna cost you right
but now we made it more convenient and
it doesn't cost any more but we will
still charge you god this make my blood
boil finish wrapping my white elephant
gift everyone needs an angle grinder I
am so confused did he wrap it in metal
and why why did you why does he do that
Wow what oh I get it cuz you can't
alright got it alright that's that's
fine really shipping method email
delivery time two to four hours email
delivery time instantly 0.43 what is it
what is in regards to I need the context
madness can we all agree having to pay
for a human necessity is a major [ __ ]
design I think if the bathroom is clean
and better maintained as a process of
paying then yes but I do agree it's fun
no you know I take it back in Japan the
land of the free Atlantis all the
toilets are clean and they don't charge
you if they can figure it out so can
everyone else mobile ads when you touch
zero one zero zero zero one centimeter
away from the center of the X button
looks like you'll go into the App Store
Jimbo
how does that work is there actually a
conversion rate of people then
accidentally click the button to the
Play Store that will make you downloaded
me like alright well I guess I'm already
here even though I didn't mean to click
on it so I guess I'll download it anyway
is that how that works that's where the
app source is promoting games to each
other like what's the economy what's
bringing money I'm so confused 1001
stickers and 768 of them are useless
squares things Disney 1001 stickers
don't discriminate against squares
includes giant wall stickers giant wall
stickers giant wall deck square that's
so funny you know why don't they show
their squares on the front cover those
are the best bits screw Ariel I want the
squares my printer just did a firmware
update and no long
recognize my third-party ink oh my god
we this makes my blood boil
oh my god this pisses me off so much oh
I've got it
piss me off because I'd spent a whole
day looking for a store that even sells
these didn't print their cartridges all
right and then once I got it the
printers because it said I was out of
black ink right so I refill my black ink
but then they say or you still need the
coloring cartridge to print with black
ink my blood is boiling I have a new one
oh boo me it's I want you to call it
boomer to k-19 is a retail $60 game they
put non skippable ads in from another
company I wonder how much they pay for
that right cuz advertising in games is
not a new thing I'm looking at you deaf
stranding if you knew what was good for
your deaf stranding you put some G fuel
ads in there okay not something beta
monster drink this design pisses me off
every single day I don't know I prefer
the cordless I'm not gonna lie I hate
the cords as much as I hate this I hate
cords more cords a spawn of Satan Satan
be like cords there will be cords now
yesterday it is announced
AT&T got hit with a 60 million dollar
fine today I get this on my account
we've added 15 gigabyte of data to your
plan and increase your monthly rate by
$10 please sign in to review the changes
to your account wow thanks
$1 for 1 gigabyte almost what a great
deal 1.2 Wow everything I hear from
American what do they call like mobile
companies it's just absolutely insane
labeling wipes that are toxic for
aquatic life and as and non degradable
as flushable harmful for aquatic life
with long lasting effects Tesco
flushable toilet buy kills 99% of
bacteria that means you have 0.1%
bacteria in your butthole three days can
we just install be days in our toilets
already with warm
toilet seats I'm sick of this this is
why because Tesco wants to sell you
flushable toilet wipes we could be
living in a society what conduct could
be real me I click X so you should close
Skype well yes but actually this card is
the same all of them I hate them all of
them I hate them all as much as I
preferred this cord God do I feel like a
Boomer when I use this court how does
that how do I add friends I don't
understand bad design discord oh yes a
classic the eyes are at an alcoholic
this should gets me every time sneaky
[ __ ] right 8% less last time eight
birds head you got a really read if it
says if you care about the alcohol
percentage you really got it look into
it alright you'll be surprised how many
[ __ ] polish or it says like 10% and
like 10% more of what here's another one
bigger pack more to share 500 grams is
this 30% bigger yeah dad dammit what
does that mean with a guy holding up the
sign in 2020 I want more potato chips in
the bag
props turd Pringles at least at least
you don't get scammed this is why we're
not living in a society that could be
what come this is why god I'm so pissed
this is why I don't trust websites
website oh I'm sorry but please we
please turn down a block me OK turns off
bad luck website download the wars today
I have hardcore sex with these cartoon
girls in a beat guys please turn off
adblock if you're watching PewDiePie
video please their worst is when you're
trying to read an article right wait we
need this for your good journalism it's
important for democracy that we have
good journalism please read our fab work
so we can have more clickbait titles my
Chinese Smart TV plays a 15 second
Chevrolet commercial every time I turn
it up why is that so funny
turn on TV you want card you want car
yes you want car you want to watch TV
now you want car this app couldn't be
uninstalled but what's disabled and it's
no longer well it's disabled all right
and it's no longer accessible to enable
it again open the apps page on the
Settings app got it well that's the same
if you try and delete your Facebook
account they're like we'll just keep it
for a keep it in the incognito just in
case you come back delay date now oh you
know what pisses me off
FedEx if you're listening FedEx [ __ ] you
what they do is all right so sometimes I
receive a bunch of unsolicited packages
all the [ __ ] time I blow it's yeah I
know
boohoo boohoo me I get free stuff but
what the a FedEx do is they're usually
there's a charge for the package right
there's a tax for whatever reason they
got two packs the package even though
it's a gift technically or samples they
got a tax it well what they do is they
don't charge you or they don't ask you
to pay they just send a letter saying
you have to pay us for what what package
they don't tell you and if we don't if
you don't pay us pull up the price scam
why should I pay you I don't even know
what I'm paying you for only if you
don't pay it's more money more money to
us it's only FedEx and that's this DHL
ask for the money at least when you get
the package so you know what you're
paying for like I wouldn't accept the
[ __ ] package if I knew I ever had to
pay taxes or detain you FedEx hope you
die in a fire so to log back on to
Facebook you need to upload a photo that
shows your face to make sure the photo
well I guess it's just to show that it's
you if you log into a new device I don't
have a problem with that
especially with how many fake accounts
there are on that website I'm a truck
driver I have an iPad mounted in my
truck
I use for TV and Netflix I'm currently
eight hundred plus miles from home
thanks for ruining one of my few
luxuries I have on the road Hulu what
you're not supposed to are you supposed
to drive and watch
I think Hulu saved your life to unlock
open hoola when you're at home do this
at least every 30 days why get out just
don't use Hulu then this is why it's
good that we have different services
even though it is kind of annoying how
many there
stop using it they'll stop pulling all
right log democracy literal hell for
budget Flyers standing seats oh wow man
the thing is like you see so many
airlines going bankrupt anyway so I
don't know what their margins are or
because generally people don't care
right they just want to fly cheap as
possible so if consumers can fly more
cheaply and this is the option I'm sure
people would do it plus it doesn't look
like you're standing you can still sit
right I'm kind of confused by this
I need more context the packaging on
this drink
oh is it only like half full the bottom
is is like yeah yeah there it is that's
hilarious
although the weights to alright here's
why this one's bill is five dollars
higher you got a discount I'm not sure
Verizon understands the meaning of
discount how does this things happen
like American mobile companies to seem
insane Microsoft games create a new
process every time it plays an ad so we
can blast it at full volume she says I
was trying avocados for the first time
turn out some genius put a rock in it to
make it look bigger
what oh sorry they're joking got it that
will be rotten if that's the case my god
I'm stupid I can't buy single-use
plastic bags at the supermarket anymore
but companies get away like this I mean
to be fair how would they package that
so people can find it right and not
steal it to be fair however the fact
that you can't use plastic bags
supermarkets just freakin annoying but
does not help anyone I think I heard
that plastic bag was a Swedish invention
there were went at it in Sweden and
there was a way to waste less paper
because they were stronger than paper
bags so the idea was that you can keep
using them and recycle them and just put
them in your pocket and then use them
again and and the thing with the cotton
bags is that they produce some what they
take so much water to produce cotton
that you're doing much more harm to the
environment
getting a cotton bag unless you reuse it
like what 600 times or something like
that instead of of just using the
plastic bags a couple more times that's
right I am so broke I understand
everything and about everyone if you
want PD PI 2020
what kinda utopia will be real forever
I love the subreddit I will definately
review it again however it's lunchtime
and I have to go thank you for watching
this video if you enjoyed its much like
subscribe and as always why am I not on
break
you haven't been training on pixel ins
will get on it cuz ranked PvP matches
are live don't call yourself a gamer
unless you're up here in PewDiePie's
picks links find the tiers get Fame
points
make 19 year-olds cry and unlock new
arenas epic oh did I mention their pics
links they're welcome
[Music]
you